so today I'll talk about roots I just
want to mention one thing before I gave
it a lot like two or three months ago at
best so most of the talk today will be
new but some of it won't so people who
are coming back who have to suffer or
enjoy again
okay so roots so what is so I called it
towards the second revolution and the
question is what is the first revolution
so the first Green Revolution is the
attributed to Professor Borlaug and it's
considered this huge increase in crop
yields mainly grain yields that we we
have seen due to use of pesticides and
new varieties but these yields got to a
plateau in the last few years with which
this yield or in a pasture and with we
are not going up to the next level so we
think because we are good people but
also trying to be objectively but the
next revolution and increasing the yield
should come from the roots since the
roots and this is towards the second
grade of evolution were until let's say
five years ago much less studied in the
above-ground it's like a 5% of
publication or were on the roots so what
do roots do is have many functions they
have anchorage water and nutrient uptake
storage biosynthesis a sexual
reproduction and communication with
other plants and with the rhizosphere
I will now I'll present to you several
studies that were carried out in my lab
these studies not dealing with wood and
just to show you how I got excited
in truth so I'll start with the first
project so the first project is the role
of route orders in water nutrient uptake
so we have this title and then the
question is what are route orders in
order to understand that it will be easy
to first understand what a river stream
orders so when you think about rivers
it's easy to think that the small Creek
goes to a mr. Chris put bigger Creek and
then put the large street and as we say
in the poem in Hebrews or withers at the
end those who the seat so this is the
main rivers at sea so the small river is
ordering one and the order that gets
orders one is order to if you an order
that gets in order to know in order
three and so this is in rivers so in
plant it's more or less the same but
it's below ground okay and but and we're
not going to the sea but we're going to
the tree now in words until and also
today most research is usually based on
diameter so we have large roots and
small roots fine roots course with
different people different and the size
is important for people and this term of
route orders came up in the literature
already a few years ago but not much
research was done about this and we were
interested to know what is the function
whether there is a function for this
specific alternate and what is this
so for that you need students or
postdocs and we had a very good postdoc
in my life both evolved
dr. Roosevelt who's now a CI at boku
University and we started to work and
trees and we decided to work on orange
trees just what we had and we owe them
hydroponic link so you see that growing
hydroponically in a nutrient solution
and then we decided to look at the root
orders for that we constructed these
chambers many chambers see here where
they in hold with them a piece of root
order could be root order one two three
different wood orders now this chamber
we connected to a scale
so the plant here this is the orange
tree growing in a nutrient solution with
our chamber the chamber is connected to
a scale with a nutrient solution now if
this area is taking water up so what
will happen to the way in the scale it
will go down the scale is connected to a
computer and by this we could know
exactly the rate of uptake of this of
every specific a root order okay this is
the hard thing to explain I hope this is
understandable so we are measuring the
uptake of different orders just by
connecting them to a scale and what we
see is here we have root orders 1 1 2 3
this is distilled water this is under
nutrient solution we saw a little bit
decrease of uptake when we have nutrient
solution versus distilled water but what
was interesting but also expected is
that root orders one the smallest with
orders or up taking much more water
nutrient solution okay so this was
expected and then the really surprising
thing and the thing that we we were
really we had to repeat and repeat in
order to make sure we understand what's
happening is when we went to the 4 & 5
root orders the large roots we saw water
coming into the scale the weight is
going up we couldn't understand what's
happening and we did and again and again
and that's what we saw so we have an
influx in root order one two three any
flux water coming out from the high root
orders now the question was whether this
is a active or passive going out of the
water I'll show you soon what we think
but for sure we have water coming out
and I'll tell you now already what what
we think is the large root orders or the
main shadows for the tree and they're
usually older
so in order to maintain a relatively wet
environment for them not to die these
route orders have both passive and
active exits of water some people talk
about hydraulic lifts in other papers so
this is kind of hydraulic weight but
this is in hydroponics okay so we have
to remember this is an aeroponic this
was the first to see that so we see this
route orders going out and we see it so
this was I did it by area when we also
when we calculated by weight so no
matter which we calculate the piece of
or roots is there is by area rate we
still see this a flux water coming out
of the hi route orders so now we said
okay let's see what happens on the
salinity so just when we grow them under
salinity we look here this different
route orders so the main effect is to
the route or the one they are
significantly decreased small holes
under salinity also what are the three
is decreased significantly but not not
very much okay so what happens when we
decrease this route order once the
hypothesis if we did with them will
decrease the uptick of water so we do
see here that this this was under
nutrient solution and when we grow them
under salinity you see weight decreased
by at least 50%
we but we also saw that the influx that
we showed doesn't exist anymore okay
there's no water coming out so this
shows us that the part of the influx
from high orders is also active it's not
also only passive effect so and then we
say okay this is under salinity now
let's give these pans we list them for a
stress for two hours we list them from
salinity what we see we see this very
large increase
of uptick so the plants are under
salinity the stress they are not taking
water you know okay and then we give
them an option with no salinity they
drink it so this is just a summary this
this is by before it was by area this is
by weight this is my area so you see
this is under control we see this very
unique efflux from high root orders
under salinity very low uptake and a
release you have a very large uptake
this is the rate of uptake to jay-c so
so this is our first project that I
wanted to tell you when we we look at
the statistics we see but in these root
orders so you say would order 1 or
smaller so maybe bit size but the most
statistical thing is the for itself okay
not the distance not where it is in the
branch not if it's up or down not if
it's the diameter the most significant
is the root order itself okay and then
we we are continuing to deal with these
root orders and we do it in different
ways so this is just I'm showing you
examples we work on papers we grow the
plants on paper so we have the roots
here and by this we could just punch the
paper with diamond see uptake of
nutrients okay next two different root
orders so we just I'll show you this was
not published yet so but this is work
that we are doing so you see the
different root orders this is just an
example for potassium then this is time
in hours they have a different uptake
behavior of nutrients so not only they
are taking water differently or solution
they're different that specifically
taking different nutrients differently
and then that also we look also
physiology so we look at the root
respiration so also the root one and two
they are more active they will spire
significantly more than the higher root
orders so what did we see so water up
the crates were determined by the
order not by diameter or distance and
what the uptick rates under solidity
decreased significantly however in
plants grown in salinity and subjected
locally to a non salt solution all our
orders showed only in flux root root
interactions I told you woods have many
roles one of them is the interaction
with the biosphere so we have a root
system here in in this root system we
have different roots right so does this
would know that knows that this roots is
the same like this hand note but belongs
to the same individual and what happens
when we know it was already published
that when you have two words together so
for some reason this root knows they're
decreasing their system okay so we
wanted to look at this root with
interactions and for that we used peas
as a model plant and what is I'll just
show you in order to understand the
terminology is this is the roots of one
individual so these are called self this
is the roots of the other individuals
are also called self in between them the
purple color versus the world color but
if this word sees this purple its
non-self okay so we have self and
non-self now what did we do we took our
piece and we split the root okay when
they are young into two platforms
the first one is self so each we have
three ports in each pot we have one
plant with its own roots okay in this
one we have three ports in each post we
have words from two different
individuals because we take the Dajjal
and it split it into two half of the
roots here half here half here half here
half here half here so all parts here
are
non-self and all parts here or so this
is clear so the last thing to do is this
is a cat scan of an answer route when
you take an x-ray and if you go to
Vienna and talk about it this is what it
reminds you I didn't get in yet the
inspiration for ethica for this so these
are our plans okay so this is self an
answer okay and then we measure route
length in the non self is significantly
decreased the so photosynthesis now the
next thing we wanted to see is what
happens to restoration where suppression
is a very important process in plants
however it's much less studied there's
almost no people in the world who
measure intact respiration of plants
although as you can see so it could a
large fraction of the assimilates could
be expended by respiration after 70% so
what this was where respiration produce
ATP NADPH or any in the age and carbon
skeleton so in my lab we developed this
not very nice looking but very effective
way to measure route respiration we
measure simultaneously both Otto and co2
okay this is our and we have these
special chambers with Stefan because the
o2 is very difficult to measure and this
is we put our plants we seal them and we
measure go and gas in and out in and out
constantly for a week okay and what do
we see we saw this very weird thing
non-self glands had 30% more respiration
so if I'm next to a neighbor I'm going
I'm nervous I'm going to a better
so the roots when they are from the same
plant for some reason they know that we
are self and when I am far I'm going
what does increased respiration give us
ATP okay lots of ATP and this comes and
the expense of carbon going to growth so
the roots are smaller and this you can
see this is both - as the co2 release
and o2 consumption and this is by time
this is just a day a night and day of
the non-self and so ok so we have these
roots that are aspiring more just
because they're seeing their neighbors
so what is the conclusion so root length
an area decreased when you have non self
with respiration increased when you have
non-self so what happens under stress
conditions and one of the most important
stresses that we work in the lab is
salinity so we look at salinity we grow
them we put hundred milli molar nacl you
see that the when yourself you are much
more affected than you in your non-self
and the same thing also happens in the
shoot and also in respiration so whisper
Asian under salinity increases but it in
both self and non-self but it increases
less in the in the non so as if we are
ready for the stress we already
respiring so much so maybe we're more
acclimated to our future stress so
non-self plants were less affected by
soul stress non-self plants in the
k-league and a possible acclamation to
future stress in lots of plants in a
feed-forward acclamation mechanism our
results provide new information and wood
restoration and now you could read the
paper so I'll go to the next thing so in
the horticultural meeting I heard a
little bit about
aeroponics here so I decided just to
show but we also do our opponents
in our lab and we when we wanted to do
it we wanted to control temperature
because we are very interested in
extreme temperatures so we the thing we
thought about is like the ice cream you
know refrigerators so we built these ice
cream refrigerators and we could control
the root temperature they're very stable
with temperature or four degrees up to
that no matter what so we have these
chillers at the end of each so and this
is how it looks so we have four
containers also and we have a nutrient
solution here they stand on a weight so
we know exactly how much water we are
giving all the time and it looks like
this so we have a chamber with four
plants and the plants are growing in the
air and we spray them every minute okay
with nutrient solution now the plants
are growing great we looked at
hydroponics soil and aeroponics they are
going the biggest wonder airponics and
the roots are more similar to soil than
hydroponics in their architecture so
this is very a very good tool to study
the roots aeroponic system so what it
what are the advantages easy access to
the root low salt the positions on the
root zone we have adequate Aviation lack
of mechanical impendence when we want to
take the roots so we're not destroying
them and the root development is similar
to the soil disadvantages or that if you
grow if you live in the desert very far
so sometimes we do have no electricity
ten minutes without electricity in the
desert the plans for this because
there's no buffer to hold the roots so
the first thing you do when you have a
student to make sure he has a smartphone
and he gets this SMSs and it the first
day it happened he got two hundred sms's
and then now it's only one bit per day
so you have to run fast to see the
plants and make sure they are ok because
most of them are false sms's and we have
very you need this technical know-how
that we
supply so I'll just show you an example
for a research that was done so this is
a graph that bell peppers taken from
companies in jente this is in
collaboration with them and we were
looking at we are very interested in
roots and different wood science based
yeah wood stocks so here we grafted
cannon and cannon and here with graphs
and Carroll innocent 1:03 and we looked
at the effect of low temperatures on the
root zone okay
so here we have the plants and we grow
them either and the 14 degrees or just
one wait for 14 degrees and then
recovery or 27 degrees and then when we
look at the above-ground its you almost
don't see differences but when you look
at the roots and it's easy to look at
the roots you see significant
differences between the 103 is much more
tolerant in the root wise than the
cannon and you could go deeper to the
woods
and look at root the projected area and
number of ticks and you see a
significant decrease so this is you
don't see anything above ground in the
vegetative stage but you do see lots
below ground and then we did a lot a lot
of research I'm not showing everything
we look at all the metabolites so I know
typically we didn't see anything in the
shoots but when you look at metabolites
in the shoots we see large differences
from control okay when they are under 14
degrees and there are less differences
in the 103 and the wood is one so this
was just an example of aeroponics and
this is also working progress so we did
publish not all yet but some of it and
now almost last topic I I know people
here are very interested in wine vines
so we also got interested in it like six
or seven seven years ago already and we
started growing Cabernet Sauvignon in
Shiraz
in our desert so white will wine vine in
the desert
first we have lots of space okay
there's life and temperature extremes or
import are good or the wine water the
lack of water is a big advantage why
when wine vines are stressed they
produce sugars and this way when we
irrigate them we could control exactly
how much water to give no surprises we
don't have water no halfway in our area
we have well here we have like 80
millimetres a year and it's only between
December to March 80 millimetres is 8
centimeters it's two and a half inches
it's not a lot if you're going more self
it's less but this is what we have and
of course the wine so we are also making
our own line we have companies and so we
have things to do so and we're not the
first one to do this the Nabateans 3,000
years ago had this winery so this is of
that 10 minute from our campus and this
is shifted 25 minutes from our campus
and all these are wine presses you see
but they had large wine making so means
there was that many wine punch board ok
and this wine was exported you know
these two cities or 3,000 years oh they
are sitting under what is called
instance route from Yemen to the port of
Gaza and then to Cyprus and you found in
Cyprus is clay bottles of wine with the
stamp of duck from 2,500 years ago so
wine was in the area and it's now being
reintroduced to the area so all the wine
vines in our area are grafted and they
are all grafted than one a Woodstock or
jury which is the tolerant Woodstock for
our area so the wood stacks of all our
Cabernet Sauvignon Shiraz whatever we
have is the same ok
so we're good this Cabana Shenyang
Shiraz the background below ground is
the same Roger Lee and we looked at the
water in the soil so we could see in
black is Shiraz Shiraz is taking much
more water than Cabernet Sauvignon
the soil is becoming much drier since
and every four days we irrigate so every
four days the water comes to the same in
both of it okay
every four do the four days she doesn't
come honest we don't slow okay same
Woodstock and then at the end of the
season we even stopped irrigating
completely this soil in Cabernet
Sauvignon
does not go down to there so there's
something differently in head radically
between them we repeat an experiment in
a greenhouse and we see again the Shiraz
is taking much more water than Cabernet
Sauvignon and this is an experiment
where we stop irrigating so you see that
Shiraz is taking much more water and
when we look at the water potential so
under non stressed conditions they are
similar under stress conditions they
both go down and then Cabana so we don't
stabilizes Shiraz continues to go down
and this these terms for that I won't go
into this but they behave hydraulically
differently and this hydraulic behavior
the different hydraulic behavior leads
also to a different photo chemical
behavior so photosynthesis electron
transport rate in the Cabernet Sauvignon
which takes less water is always higher
than in Shiraz as if soon maybe across
tamata I need to be efficient okay and
this all the time open I'm less
efficient
okay so hydraulic and photochemical
behaviors differently and we think we
understand why and also the wine itself
when we looked at the wine so this is
all the metabolites so in Shiraz and
this is in in this case is the bravery
itself for local
skin and the leaves so Shiraz is much
more sensitive to this drought
you see many metabolites are changing
all the colors in Cabernet Sauvignon
it's much more moderate the changes so
we are interested in roots so what we
did is we have this field and we put
these mini Reisman tubes to 2 meters
deep and looked at roots we look at
roots will measure every 12 millimetres
up to the deaths of two meters and this
is and we do it even more like that so
this is our tubes when after we dug the
two meters we put them in and we put
them in two distances 25 centimeters and
75 centimeters from the trunk so we have
a knowledge of the root system going
like this and going like that so we get
the impression of a 3d what's happening
below ground okay we are also measuring
two distances and also down to the dirt
and this is how it looks and these are
the roots and we could see how the root
dynamics what's happening and what was
quite amazing for us is first of all is
how deep these woods go because this is
drip irrigation if I understand
we didn't think we'll get over half a
meter or meter we get to 2 meters easily
and this is in a Cabana some lunch
service when there are 20 weather close
to the stock so we see roots in both of
them
but when we go further from the trunk
you see no roots in shiraz only in
Cabernet Sauvignon so Chile's is growing
like this come on now someone's going
like this but this is the same root
system so Roger II the root system is
reacting to it above ground to the
different physiological characteristics
and one is going like this
shira's one is going like this same root
system or Juba and this is how it looks
so we count the root so this is 25
centimeters this
75 centimeter so this is the red is
Cabernet Sauvignon the blue is Shiraz so
she has behaved in a near an idyllic way
whereas cabana severe anemia I'd week
and this behavior was correlated to high
water transport I didn't show all the
results but it was also a combined by
photochemical efficiency and would
distribution and dynamics change
according to the Scion so we think if we
have wine vine irrigation
it should take into account the cut the
cultivar specific water behavior
although never nobody does it until now
okay last topic so so line enemies this
is an amazing plant it was the plant I
was most interested when I got to this
place the desert this is an summer
annual plant so this plant is a very
small plant with very shallow roots 15
centimeters
it's an annual plant that grows only in
the summer so germinates around March
April stay small until June then it
starts to grow its with maximum October
November flowers and dies no rain
between March and November
no rain okay so it's an amazing pattern
I was interested it because I was
looking at I thought about you I won't
talk to you about it today I'll talk to
you only about what's happening below
ground so we take to this plant I came
when I dug it out and after I dug it I
saw this thing again I crushed it and I
get something mushy in my hand I thought
what it is and we have these mud huts so
it's not a pizza hut it's a mud hut and
we have many mud huts one plant could
have one mud heart
some of them three too many mud huts
what is it you go inside and serve
crushing it like I did the first time I
open it slowly and I see a weaver so
there's
a thousand weevils in the world 50,000
no weevils are known to live with plants
without harming them below ground okay
when you talk to farmers about weavers
they're all scared in Israel the palm
tree industry is a very important
industry the date trees called us or the
quarter tree because each date is silk
sold for quarter so and they're very
afraid of weevils they're killing the
trees the Wiggles but our we vote not
only they're not killing them as I'll
show you they are living together and
you'll see the wood is not harmed at all
so we see larvae we saw papa we see we
will see all these terms that I learned
to know now I'm becoming like an
entomologist and eggs we also see well
I'll show you as soon so we have this
weavers see very nice so this is the
main Weaver we see the corner windows
fill the Romani it's nice and cool
pictures to show people you know sit
inside I'll show you there half a year
and then they after I could open it and
then we go out so I had a very good
student oven Sheriff
and he did a lot of observations and
working and we made this so they're out
the weevils out at two months from the
year then they go below ground okay
there's a lava here so a small plant has
a small lava a big plant has a big lava
okay and adult plant flowering has an
adult and this is in blue is the
rainfall and these are the temperatures
average temperatures and this is also so
they grow together the river and the
plan small together big together and
then we decided to analyze roots because
that's what we do in the lab we analyze
roots so far were very big surprise
woods with rebels had 30% more nitrogen
they had
fourteen percent less carbon so we were
showing at the beginning that this is
what our conclusion from that was the
woods are getting nitrogen from the
weevils and giving sugars carbon to the
weevils as a result seeds of weevil of
the plants which levels were bigger this
is what now today was just a the second
paper in this story was except was it's
on line today already and they and we
showed I'm not the P I cause other this
paper was rejected from nature in front
then I left it for three years and then
I gave it to another collaborator made
me nervous
so but the plants are also bigger when
you have weevils so not we're not sure
if the weevils are going to big plans or
they're helping them to go bigger we
know we don't know what is the egg and
what is the hen you know in order to
know what is their cover the hen you
send them by mail and see what's coming
first so this is where the the the we
made measurements from different areas
from the mother okay but this is very
close to the mother their most
significant when they're close and then
we said okay where's the nitrogen coming
today to the plant okay this wood has
more nitrogen and we look at the weevils
in the guts we saw DNA of nitrogen
fixing bacteria so we have it three ways
in biosis we have a bacteria living
nicely having enjoying its life in the
Weaver have the weevil and the plant
everybody or profiting
but we started with the DNA in also the
adults and for two years we couldn't see
nitrogen fixation
we only saw it in jalapa took us two
years to understand we have to look at
the larvae so lava has nitrogen fixation
all have the genes for this Graziella
nitrogen if if genes are that let us
that take nitrogen which is a very
limiting factor in the desert nitrogen
these are the limiting factors so just
to remind her we saw a small plant
swallow a big plant big lava so we
wanted to show that sugar is going to
the plant to from the plant to the lava
yes and what we did is we took our plant
when it was small we knew it a small
lava yes and we did the French
Revolution to it we stopped the factory
of sugars right what happened we we
created the factory for midgets all the
small larvae who pitted and became
midgets all died okay when sugar stops
to come becomes four so ever this
three-way and this is an amazing system
and we are continuing to look at that
this is the Dr Mahathir collie who is a
new researcher in our Institute and I
just smallest gave her the project and
she's doing wonderful things we said and
we did a very large survey like 16
different places in our desert every
place we go we find this fellow he say
they say this hot mud huts the way
symbioses every way and only at this
Isola minimus you see this is all the
sites we checked and the percentage so
some areas the plants get up to almost
50 over 50 percent of the plants have
lava but some only fibers when we
started we found we looked at this area
and we had only 5% so this is part of
the thing that people didn't like this
cell not not important but you see it's
everywhere and it's correlated to
nitrogen so you have when you have more
nitrogen in the soil you have more more
weevils
and also nitrate and it's this is
correlated positively with nitrogen
nitrogen but correlated negatively with
sand and positively with silt so texture
and nitrogen are correlated with this
weebles so what happened when the plant
dies the
guys if rain comes the weevil says okay
I'll go elk okay I have nothing to do it
there's no plant anymore so I'm thinking
I'm not very fast yes I'm a weevil yeah
so so I'm going there slowly I'm saying
hi to everybody don't feel one or
something another and so this is the
adult yes so what happens when you have
a lava a small plant we have a lava so
we open this lava and look at it will it
go out like it's about so it's a lava
so it's still not very developed so it's
slow in thinking but then it gets to a
decision yes a thinks thinks thinks to
go out or not no I will stay inside and
I'll build my house and get some sugars
and I do water from the plant
give it some nitrogen live together with
my bacteria
so this is our lava now when you have
hosts that's working in this nuclei so
you have these cameras everybody has the
camera so this was taken with a cell
phone in the field we mounted our pan we
put now bine order to have some weevils
and we see this Widow I told you we did
so it's digging you see
so it's digging a hole in order to get
to the roots and then you'll see when
the hole is good enough soon so see so
takes it and then you see it's good
enough so I'm turning okay I'll turn and
I have see here the egg look at the egg
the egg is coming but I have to sit down
and relax in order for it to come out
you know with in and out so I'm relaxing
this will take another minute for this
relaxation and then relax
so we have the reverse today yeah from
from over to something with you from two
and a half three centimeters I have two
they're not not not some are small some
are big depending on the species when
they eat leaves so this plant so when we
put them on the wrist is the plant this
is some of the problems we encountered
yes they could kill this time but
usually they don't ease when they have
other now in the summer this morning
the only annual there they have some
perennials so they eat perennials okay
the larvae doesn't harm the root okay so
see here it's finished
okay the egg is there a black eye post
and then if we continue we'll see how it
is covered and this is an amazing story
I think now because of all these root
things we I we have developed what we
call root of the matter which I'm
directing it's sponsored for seven
million dollars and we are just the base
money we are collaborating with we have
20 pies in our root of the matter we are
collaborating with different companies
that only add some more funds we have so
we have this a website you go root of
the matter you see a dentist and another
dentist and will see us and then we have
three projects we see now a root of the
matter grafting which I'm a part of it
I'm also managing the grafting we are
looking to graft vegetables of tomatoes
and melons in order to improve their a
biotech tolerance okay and look at root
all kind of root characteristics how to
monitor blog below ground and how to add
bacteria in order to enhance now the
nice thing is that we have we have a
neutral
research areas so we all work together
okay and this is one of our this is just
now from week ago this is one of our
greenhouse net houses where you see the
tomatoes we have also bacteria we're
looking at the root and how to monitor
we're doing everything in our
greenhouses and we are really really
excited about this root of the matter
now I would like to thank all the people
who helped this is part of my lab and
this is our great place in Slovakia okay
if you come to the desert in Israel you
should come to step okay this is our
Oasis you could swim
you could have snow even have a water
phone to see the flood yeah this is our
campus it's a great place to be not only
scenery we have flowers okay it's desert
but we have flowers we have endemic
irises tulips
we have everything here we have all our
animals know this these are endemic
these are not we have a breakfast all
away so gardens are very well protected
because they eat everything
we have also vultures and of course our
vehicles okay I would like to invite you
to the 10th
International Society of water stats
conference which will be held in Israel
we are organizing it so it won't be in
the desert because you don't have enough
place to accommodate it will be not far
from Jerusalem and deadline for
submitting is February 14th if you are a
student we have a special student
ambassador program where we which will
be in our Institute where we sponsor
everything for you so time is limited
please submit and have fun thank you
[Applause]
question with the self and non-self
recruit think over Peas yes big what
would you see the same thing if you used
clones so the plants that you were doing
the self and non-self were genetic we
think yes and we also we think also the
question could be even if you we do
different species we think that if we
look at different species the effects
will be much smaller because the
competition for resources is smaller
when you go to genetically identical the
competition should go increase and it
will we didn't do it but we believe it
will increase I've got a question and I
like your work excuse me and on the root
order so remember that in corn roots
there's constrictions between them where
that junction between the first order
roots and the second order root is a
very high hydraulic resistance right
there are you seeing comfortable things
to notice no so we just the wood orders
thing we looked only at we don't see it
we don't see we looked at these orange
trees and now we're looking at Tomatoes
Tomatoes we don't see this thing that
you're talking about in corn very
interesting it just could increase the
effect I think what you're saying
yes so with your evil story which is
fascinating for victory that an insect
which is borrowing into and eating the
roots is actually having a symbiotic
effect so how how do you simulate the
increase in nitrogen is occurring so I
don't think that eating first of all the
roots they're not eating the just
getting exudates from the roots and the
nitrogen is just you know the wafers are
going to the toilet and the plant is
getting metropolises okay we really
tried very hard to grow them in these
volumes but no success and just what we
saw as weevils or going Oh everywhere so
we are still trying so in hydroponics in
ways we don't see this so we don't see
them it's going in a hydroponics so the
plan doesn't know they don't develop
them so in hydroponics this is yeah it
would be very nice to go to the field
and look at written we won't be able to
look or just on the hair we need to look
at cultivars which here and without here
oh yes this is this is a thing we
thought of doing as the next looking at
plants we said correlation we say
correlation when we have more weevils
have more nitrogen again I don't know
what is the egg what is the hen maybe
the weavers are going to an area with
more nitrogen we don't know in both I
thought at the end I saw a correlation
was nitrate and nitrogen in the soil so
we looked at six in different areas
abundance of of we've of
when we had more we both we had more
nitrogen and nitrate the study with
peppers were the root stocks where they
closely related of the same strain yeah
they're closely propagated but they're
from a company so the truth is I don't
know exactly
okay so it's not easy working with
companies I don't know can we run out of
time but thank you so much sheep on for
a fascinating this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell edu